[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from chefs club counter in Goleta the
brand new home of one of the most
talked-about breakfast sandwiches in the
entire country
involves needs of the neighborhood LA's
infamous egg [ __ ] is already drawing
wraparound minds in Manhattan and today
I'm joined by the man behind the brioche
bun
Alvin kai-lan is here to talk about what
makes the perfect breakfast sandwich
what is the perfect PC in your opinion
for me has to be hot has to have good
bread
if the breads stale or if it sucks ruins
your whole experience and then obviously
gooey egg you know nice sauce good
cheese and bacon you eat with your eyes
first so for me breakfast sandwich in
the morning to get your day going has to
look beautiful you want to be like [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna get down on that you know
today we're doing a little taste test on
some of the most popular breakfast
sandwiches on the market I've been
around the breakfast sandwich block a
few times you and me both but we're
gonna do a little autopsy on each and
every one of these and then we're gonna
hop into the kitchen and make a little
egg [ __ ] action yeah this is the money
right there that American cheese as a
breakfast sandwich chef what are its
traits what are its weaknesses well the
strength is is that it
so they put crack in it it's great when
you're drunk and I'm glad that they have
it all day now I'm not gonna hate on it
too much cuz I still love it still my
heart
I'm giving it a solid four point three
for the price the
assistance II it always delivers on what
it promises I'd say three point eight
three for it being great in nostalgia
eight for it to be like sinful I always
feel like they're trying to do this like
high-end artisanal sandwich it always
comes out like a mass-produced kind of
crummy cheap food item that they'd serve
on like a Delta flight and that's this
right here which is shudder not American
cheese so it's just when you bite into
it just dry right like at least if you
had American cheese and be like kind of
soft and gooey this is one one five I
would love to have a croissant that is a
bun that's awesome but it fails
everywhere else a little bit softer I'm
kind of an easy teacher right I'm gonna
give it a two point six because I do
like the bread bacon action can use some
work they actually give you a
substantial amount of bacon that's like
three slices not bad
all right next up we have a bagel
breakfast sandwich it doesn't look like
much Oh mines you can see it's like
astronaut food guys gravity yeah and
then there's that like canned egg thing
or it's like comes in the can they just
slice it
nothing sriracha can't fix that bagel is
terrible I'd say three five maybe since
I'm a bagel freak and the bacon has two
smokiness to it I'm gonna give it a
three point three that's like a certain
quality to it where like it doesn't even
matter what you order off of their
breakfast menu like it'll all more or
less taste the same and that's kind of
what I got from it so this is this is
what I'm excited about
so stacking this up your classic NYC Dec
bodega sandwich right here that weights
up like this like the egg is like
picture [ __ ] but it's so good the ratio
is on point the egg the cheese the bacon
just cut through the layers and then you
have sort of this like stepped on bread
situation yeah it's like perfect amount
of bread enough filling and - and you
bite through it I'm getting hints I'm
getting notes of all the other things
that they've been cooking on there yeah
the only thing I'm missing is a
mayonnaise packet and me sitting on the
curb but I'm a nun in Cyprus I feel like
I know where this is going what are you
giving it out of five yeah I mean as
closest I pay a four point eight I'm
giving it a solid four point nine just
uptick a little bit to keep my soft
teacher thing going bodega to bodega
they all seem to do it the same way they
all seem to do it right this is like
home we've had sort of these you know
little starters but we need that good
good that first thing in the morning
that hangover cure time for an awkward
segue to the kitchen
now me and Alvin are back in the kitchen
we're gonna make the best damn breakfast
in which you've ever seen in your life
with a little menu item eggs like calls
the Fairfax it's our boy and so our
sandwiches are go to that starts off how
every best scrambled egg starts which is
a cold pack like no heat nothing to grab
a couple eggs let's see if I can do it a
little bit better this time our main man
Oscar in the back he's having fun with
this yeah look at that you don't want to
salt it you just want to leave it like
that add a little bit of butter and then
this is where you start mixing it no
again cold pan this is like the
bamboozlement of it all because people
think you add cheese to it or like cream
but it's really just keeping the the
butter cold it emulsified in the in the
eggs so when you get it to like this
point where it's like some white we'll
go ahead and throw it on the heat and
you notice I haven't seasoned it at all
and the butter hasn't broken from the
eggs yet so it's not like oily the trick
to making really good eggs besides slow
and slow and spinning it all the time is
if it looks like it's a little
undercooked in the pan it's already done
hit them with the chives and chives and
eggs for me are like the best thing when
you in you mix it together it's almost
like truffle I like to take it off the
heat so it doesn't conceal cook these
look like some good-ass eggs yeah
there are buns on here just a little
just a little bit little just a shot
it's like give
and then once it gives you have our
sriracha mayo no scale no big deal
and you throw that bad boy on there this
has no bacon I can't cross those lines
here in New York man like they think I
can cheese a sacred you leave it as is
it's definitely a if it ain't broke
don't fix the type of thing but we're
introducing soft scramble which some
people don't like they're a little
squeamish on it because they've never
had it you're probably thinking oh man
like that's just going to fall apart
when I eat it but when you grab the
cheese again we use cheddar then we just
melted a little action but a little yeah
action this is like we call this the
finesse it's like a cheese wheel you
know and then that believe it or not oh
I'm Mach yeah it keeps it together
lastly we grab these caramelized onions
add a little sweetness how many of these
do you think you've made in your life we
do about 40,000 sandwiches a month at in
downtown and I've done it for the past
five six years so a lot and then you
just lit it BAM
forty thousand egg sandwiches worth of
practice behind you I know that I'm in
good hands there it is here it is very
IG friendly eggslut
time to take a bite
mm custardy egg you got that spicy
sriracha mayo on it the bun perfectly
toasted breakfast sandwiches you can't
really mess them up you want an Egg
McMuffin go get an Egg McMuffin right
but you want the real real one we got to
get that hangover cure let's the eggs
love right there finesse it's finesse